[Music]
so my name is Sebastian I'm a customer
engineer or solutions specialist
depending on what day of the week the
reorg is and as a result I do actually
work in sales now I know that's going to
be a little bit weird people want to
hear about like hardcore site
reliability engineering and things like
that
so what I thought I would do though
because I end up working with a heck of
a lot of customers is kind of break down
the principles that we have and marry
them with the products that you may or
may not be familiar with because a lot
of times when I go to customers they're
like oh man I love what your SRE team is
doing it's super awesome it's super
great I bought both of the books which
by the way available for free if you
just google them but at the same time
like what what do I actually do to start
implementing some of these best
practices so with that I'm going to do
that and then afterwards I'm going to
try to keep some time for more Q&A
because I want it to be a little bit
more about empowering you guys as
opposed to just me talking about random
things as we kind of go along so just as
a quick little recap here here are our
principles right now don't try to read
necessarily the things that are on the
screen the guy who reviewed my slides
was like hey by the way this is like
super small it's like yep it is super
small but in general we like publish
these things like several years ago but
in broadly we've got eliminating toil
automation released engineering
simplicity embracing risk vessels and
monitoring my apologies to boiling down
the entire automation thing to just
automate all the things but for the most
part that's kind of the mentality that I
like when it comes to that particular
category the way that I like thinking
about these things however is to kind of
put them in buckets if some of them
overlap and a lot of them are kind of
like integrated with some other
components so let's go ahead and put
these in some buckets so first of all I
have one bucket over here for simplicity
anything that you're building generally
speaking should be as simple as possible
and that's not just like keep it simple
stupid but if you find yourself using a
particular tool and you're like wow you
know I have to do a lot of work in order
to get this
to work properly or there's a lot of
glue code I have to write around it a
lot of extra scripts chances are you
might be doing something that runs
opposite or against the grain of what
that tool is designed to do or what
you're trying to accomplish so in
general though the other buckets that
we've got here we've got eliminating
spoil and automation I put that in the
stop doing things manually buckets over
in release engineering I think that's a
kind of a big important thing in and of
itself so that gets its own bucket and
then lastly bucket three here is all
about embracing risk having the SOS and
monitoring so it's all about
establishing the appropriate SSL is
figuring out what your SSL lows are
going to be and making sure that you're
monitoring them so you can do those
appropriate calculations so now that
we've got these types of buckets let's
approach each one of these buckets and
then I'll show you some of the GCP
products and services that we have that
make it very easy for you to build say a
planet-scale computer that is properly
monitored properly metric and is
somewhat reliable but first there is
actually a catch
now what would this catch actually be
well it turns out that when you want to
do things like hermetic builds and if
you want to do things like have
appropriate monitoring and whatnot you
need to have an underlying platform that
is responsive and capable of running
these types of things you want something
that has built-in automation built-in
orchestration monitoring and so on and
so forth so what I'm gonna say is the
catch here is that you're going to use
something like the components inside of
anthos or formerly the cloud services
platform but we added a few things on
top of it now I'm not saying you have to
use that particular product just that
that product is actually a meta product
that actually encompasses a heck of a
lot of other components for example here
which are I guess they're kind of
showing up there you've got a couple
extra components you might see here on
the periphery things like Kay native
you've got st own and kubernetes down
there
you've got cloud build and you've got
the rest of the sort of the GCP
portfolio down here so let's dive in we
things but just to kind of give you a
quick like recap of why I think this is
a really awesome platform so that we're
on the same page we've got a handful of
these different types of components
explained here right so we've got
application centric runtime
configuration orchestration which is all
of the words in your buzzword bingo so
go ahead and check that one off but in
general it's it's basically like you
need to have a declarative system that
says I want these things to be running
in this fashion right the core of sree
to me is all about the programmatic
operation of your infrastructure your
infrastructure powers your applications
your applications are tied to your
business goals which means that your
programming your business that's what
this is all about trying to remove
people from the equation while still
making sure that things run properly and
your reactive and your continuing with
your development the other thing that I
like about anthos and and CSP and all of
it the components that are inside it are
it's built from open source compute or
components which means it's hybrid and
multi cloud so anything I'm preaching up
here today you can take with you
regardless of where you want to deploy
it I think you'll find that of course
again being in sales that it runs really
well on our platform because it's nice
and integrated and things like that but
it's designed to allow you to get to
that right once run anywhere mentality
that we were talking about people like
yours we're talking about people like
Thomas curry and we're talking about the
other thing is it gives you things like
hermetic builds and containers because
it's all container orchestration and
container automation so you check that
right off your box
the other cool thing that you've got is
built-in support for things like canary
deployments and roll bags if something
goes wrong you want that mean time to
recovery to be very very short very very
quick so you can get things working
again I don't miss it
without using sort of kubernetes in that
entire stack but it's painful and I
don't like doing that sort of thing
containers on the other hand it's
literally one command and then you're
all set
and then the last thing I like the fact
that you can get service level telemetry
which is a really cool component that
I'm going to talk about a little bit
later keep in mind all of this is
designed to keep developers and
operators
like the reason why we're putting these
things together is not just because it's
yet another new technology that we think
is an interesting technology we want you
to do it in a particular way
kudos to Ivy anthos team for getting a
round of applause but the reason why
we're putting this things together is to
make your lives easier to be able to run
those services reliably and without
spending a heck of a lot of time trying
to configure something the the tagline
that I always use when I give
presentations is infrastructure for the
sake of infrastructure is pointless in
the sense of like if I have to build up
a bunch of infrastructure to run the
other infrastructure then I have
infrastructure over here that still
needs to be managed and configured and
monitored and so forth the further you
are away from actually running just an
application which is tied to your
business goal the less efficient your
overall system is so with that in mind
let's dive into the first first bucket
that we have this first bucket is
automation and toil I want to start with
that one
why well predominantly because
automation and toil are easy things to
sort of tackle especially in our
platform so if we go back to the diagram
here this is sort of the overall diagram
of anthos and some of the products that
are inside of it so where would say
automation and toil if we really want to
focus on that what products what I
recommend how would I recommend using
that sort of thing well it turns out
it's actually all of them because
everything in a cloud computing
environment is API driven so anything
that you want to do is naturally going
to be scriptable it's going to be
callable and it's going to be integrated
in the rest of the platform one of the
nice benefits of like the promise of
cloud computing in general is that
everything that you have can just be
invoked with some sort of API call and
then you're done you don't have the
equivalent of an API call for a person
to have something like remote hands you
don't have like order procurement
purchasing racking and stacking and
things like that you can just hit it and
kind of go from there however
the value that you end up getting from
having an entire system be automatable
an entire every tire system being able
to be easily scripted is that you have
this API centric design right the the
concept of an API centric design as
opposed to a design that has like
clients and other random things is that
we build the API first and then we
figure out which clients we want to
build as a result of that later on so
your g-cloud command that you run or
your console command that you run if you
ever run that little command on the
bottom it says like view the equivalent
JSON post or view the equivalent g-cloud
command to your clicks it's all the same
stuff I get a handful of customers that
always ask me like well well how do I
make sure that a person has access to
this but not access to that and we
always have to remind them like the well
it's actually the API call that you
really want to be focusing on here it's
not necessarily restricting access to
just the command line or just something
else so that's kind of important but I
want to focus a little bit more on coil
to recap coil this is the the SOA
definition of toil that I pulled right
from the book I'll kind of paraphrase it
here but in general you're running a
production service you're doing work to
be able to enable that particular
production service it doesn't have a lot
of enduring value and usually the state
of the system is is sort of left the
same my apologies to this group of the
the audience who's having difficulty
reading that sort of rain apologize
anyway in to try to eliminate toil you
have to ask yourself like why am I doing
this particular task if I have to like
bootstrap a bunch of stuff even in a
cloud environment like can we go set up
the you know organization can we set up
all of these particular modes the
firewall rules the monitoring and these
sorts of things if you're doing that
manually repeatedly every time you want
to deploy something every time you want
to get something up and running or
recover from failure or something like
that your end up you're spending a lot
of time doing work that isn't
necessarily driving value for your
company or your organization so I want
to focus on a couple of the interesting
products that we've got in this area
we look back to the components we can
orchestrate pretty much all of this fun
stuff and how do we do that
well big popular things that we've got
are things like cloud deployment manager
which is basically just you know a JSON
ee Emily Python e-type thing that you
define your infrastructure hit the
button and then boom we take it and run
it for you you can do the same thing
with say Hashi corpse terraform i think
they have a booth somewhere around here
we like them a lot and we also like them
enough that we include terraform in the
cloud show for example what I'm getting
at here is the left two big blocks here
our infrastructure is code again we get
back to that notion of a declarative
infrastructure where you define how your
infrastructure is going to be built once
and then you let something else figure
out how to move this state to that
desired state all right I also want to
mention we've got like cloud functions
over here we've got service architecture
that allows you to have an event-driven
workflow meaning like if I want to talk
to cloud functions or if I want to do
something else and key off of some other
event that's happening cloud functions
is a really good solution to be able to
do that speaking of which here's an
interesting piece of architecture that's
that I took right from our client at
google.com belong this is one of the I
think documented things on how to do
Auto inserts if you upload a file into
GCS so if you take a look here
again apologies to these guys you upload
a file into a cloud storage back-end you
then figure out how to move that into
say bigquery to be able to do with
analytics and other fun stuff off of
that what's nifty about it is it's a
pipeline so you've just defined a
pipeline that you don't have to stand up
requisite infrastructure to be able to
listen for these types of events it's
included just within cloud functions so
if you're doing something and it's let's
say that tasks that you need to do to
continue serving whatever the output of
this particular pipeline would look like
you can leverage cloud functions to key
off of those types of event triggers and
then take steps on your behalf
the other thing which is kind of cool
about this is odd functions are just
little tiny like JavaScript ear every
phase which means that you don't
necessarily have to be a full SDK
developer to figure out what's going on
usually it's just I listen for an event
I figure out some JSON and I post it to
another back-end and then it kind of
works well together again going back to
that API centric design that I was
talking about before however we've got
some other interesting tools that I want
to talk about one of the ones that I
don't think it's a lot of credit these
days is cloud composer cloud composer is
a really powerful tool that a lot of
kind of really big enterprise companies
that I work with like taking a look at
that you might say well why is that like
what the heck is this darn thing anyway
well first of all it's a really cool
Tetris piece I mean that's pretty nifty
there but the other thing is it's Apache
airflow so you might ask yourself okay
what's Apache your flow well it's a
bunch of dads okay what's a de a
directed acyclic graph in other words
it's a if this then that kind of thing
not the company necessarily but the
principle of implementation tags work in
basically just like a standard like flow
chart type thing so you can program
certain specific tasks to be done
imagine if you wanted to have a portal
of some sort created where you can
provision infrastructure based on the
requests of your users and by users I
mean not necessarily your end users but
you know corporate users something like
that like hey I need a VM to go do
something or hey I need this other thing
to be stood up maybe it's a complex
series of steps which actually requires
invocation you might have written a
bunch of terraform before but now you're
constantly modifying it as these new
requests come up so what do you do
something like cloud composer can do
that for you also what it can do which
is kind of interesting is you can
schedule an invocation or schedule an
execution of whatever you've programmed
meaning that repeated tasks that you
might be doing
hence like you know something that's a
really great candidate for toil can now
be autumn
and schedule the way for you to run
repeatedly give you a great example of
this this is automatic backups like
would it be great if you leveraged like
the snapshotting functionality that we
have inside of our state of GCE VMs at a
regular interval you package it up and
then ship it and take it and have it go
do something as a result you can do this
you don't have any manual processes to
do this and you don't really have like a
lot of coding should be done because it
has a very easy to understand sort of
programming language that invokes all of
these things likewise you don't have to
allocate resources for that to be run on
if you were to say hey I got a bunch of
Python to automate this I would go cool
where are you gonna run it I got to give
you a server to be able to run your
Python and then I got to be able to give
it credentials to be able to make those
API calls well with cloud Composer you
can just write it there click the button
and then it goes in schedules things
which is really handy the other cool
thing is it integrates with the rest of
the cloud based on its SDK so if you
want to automate anything not just like
GCE VMs but literally anything that we
might have in the cloud that's a good
way to do that so if you wanted to ask
me like hey how do I get started with
more automation reducing some toil in my
enterprise right now I would say
infrastructure as code solutions cloud
functions and cloud composer take a look
at all of them figure out where it can
be used in your infrastructure and then
take it from there next up we've got
release engineering I love release
engineering because being that DevOps
guy I do a lot of DevOps II type things
and one of those things is of course is
setting up CI CD pipelines I always like
to say CI CD CA because I think it's
important to be able to continuously
audit whatever you have already built
inside your infrastructure to make sure
that you're in compliance with whatever
you wanted to build so if we go back to
the little chart here what piece am I
actually talking about it's that one
right there cloud built I really like
cloud built like I really like it why do
I like it well first of all I basically
just point it at a source repo and then
I say trigger off of these tags and it
goes and it builds my containers for me
again they're the requisite
infrastructure we're talking about
container native what's great about that
is because of the prevalence of
microservices an emphasis on micro like
we're not building like six big
containers here with building small
containers very frequently integrating
things like unit tests into it so that
you have saved some go codes and java
codes and Python whatever it happens to
be it will build that compile it run the
unit tests build the docker container
push the docker container up tag the
docker container and be ready to go
that's super powerful not only is that
super powerful but because everything
like I said is API driven an event
specific you can then key off of that so
for example one of the great pieces of
solution architects develops pipelines
that we've got takes cloud build takes
spinnaker which is a great open source
continuous deployment mechanism and then
puts them together so spinnaker watches
for new images inside the docker
registry that builds those images and
pushes them up which is pretty nice but
I want to focus on sort of the like the
kind of the the principles that we're
trying to solve here right so if we
think about release engineering here's a
here's a couple different choice words
from the SRA handbook self-service high
velocity hermetic builds enforcement of
releases in a pragmatic continuous way
that before docker became super popular
if you were to if I were to put this
slide up to an audience full of industry
professionals
he'd be like hermetic builds like what
are you guys talking about now that we
have the concept of containers widely
available and everyone sort of agreed on
them this is a heck of a lot easier to
UM say to get stood up I want to focus
on two of the words that are there well
it might be interesting or might be
tempting to focus on continuous because
you got continuous integration and
continuous delivery I actually want to
focus on hermetic and I want to focus on
enforcement these are kind of
interesting developments here number one
if you're building a bunch of stuff but
your build environment is constantly
changing
you're never building the same thing if
you kick off a build and you kick off a
build of the exact same source repo in
the exact
thing we should get the exact same sha
sum at the end of that build there
shouldn't be any weird introduction back
and forth that is easier to accomplish
with things like micro-services and
easier to accomplish with things like
containers or another word here's some
nice blue hexagons to help you out with
this
you've got container builder and you've
got the container registry again you
don't have to worry about standing up
infrastructure to be able to host all of
these containers in a secure way in a
private way with the appropriate amount
of Identity and Access Management on top
of it and you don't have to worry about
how to build all of these things like
how do I run that you know go build or
how do I run that Java C command this
will do that for you the other cool part
about here we can actually have some
enforcement stuff taken care of like I
mentioned through cloud I am and here's
spinnaker over here so a lot of
questions I also get in terms of setting
up CI CD pipelines from customers are
well that's great I get the concept of
building this you know this application
or this container or something like that
but how do I get that for production how
do I make sure that that's deployed in a
way that makes sense where I have the
appropriate change control how do I do
that well actually spinnaker allows you
to do that right out of the box as a
matter of fact spinnaker is natively
aware of things like kubernetes as a
deployment target understands natively
out-of-the-box things like GCP so it
understands how to work with AIIMS work
with credentials and so forth to make
those things happen and not only that it
also understands how to do the
appropriate change mechanism so that
you're in compliance with whatever
regulated industry you happen to be in
here's a really cool architecture that
our wonderful solution architects have
put together so you got cloud build
spinnaker equals happy I like that it's
CI CD made easy your developers
essentially get commits get push that's
it they don't have to do anything else
it pushes up to a cloud source
repository cloud build picks it up
figures out how to build it and test it
at the unit test level builds they
appropriate docker container pushes the
docker container up spinnaker figures
out that oh you've got a new
automatically because it's configured to
do this in this architecture
automatically deploys a canary
deployment sends a certain amount of
traffic to that canary and then waits
for you to click the button to update
the percentage of what you're sending to
the new version so let's say you're
doing a 10 percent 90 percent split
waits for you to push the button on 2
percent of the traffic rolls over to the
new version in other words it kind of
looks like this this is the flowchart of
what that looks like so you you change
some code check it in it detects a new
tag builds the appropriate image and
then eventually hands it over to
spinnaker that does that release
although this stuff by the way for
people that are taking pictures is
available on cloud.google.com these are
literally just screenshots that I'd
circle actually I copied the picture
which is kind of fun
so if you want to head there if you
actually just google things like
continuous integration spinnaker look
for the first cloud.google.com
entry and this actually walks you
through everything you need to deploy
along with code samples count charts and
things that you would need to actually
get this stood up and working properly
the important thing the all-important
click that managers and CEOs and and
other types of executives want to see is
the we didn't just push this to
production and broke everything
this little man icon here that's the I'm
waiting for a human to be involved
before I make a decision so this is
literally a screenshot of spinnaker push
to production yes or no continue stop
you hit the continue button that's
deployed and then you're all set
do you have to write all of the
additional glue code in order to get
this up and running and working no
that's literally what spinnaker is works
natively on the platform works really
well with things like cloud build so
again you can go from 0 to continuous
integration and delivery pipeline that's
enforced based on the change management
process that you want without having to
do a lot of extra work hence why I
called the talk batteries included
DevOps and batteries included sre by the
way we have a great YouTube video which
talks about the difference between
DevOps and sre I love the way they
summed it up they've got really cool
shirts which is class sre implements
DevOps
I really love that as an object-oriented
guy I kinda like that any good last one
I want to talk about which is
most important one is monitoring an s
ellos this is the big one everything up
until now you you're probably going
depending on your familiarity with cloud
native architectures you're like yeah I
get that
like I get how to build a container I'm
sold on the whole kubernetes thing and
what have you done for me lately well if
you haven't taken a look at some of
these really awesome monitoring systems
this is going to be super fun for you if
we go back to the architecture diagram
what am I talking about
I'm talking about this bad boy down here
stack drivers service monitoring now
wouldn't it be great if as I'm deploying
all of these services into production or
even into a staging environment or
development environment logging and
monitoring happens out of the box
without having additional configuration
without having to stand up my own elq
stack or my efk stack or anything else
what if it just knew how all of this
stuff worked that's what I'm going to
talk about right here but I'm going to
talk about some of the advanced stuff as
well stack driver service monitoring is
a really fascinating brand-new thing
that we kind of rolled out so what is it
well it's sre monitoring made very easy
now why do I say it's sre monitoring and
not just sort of regular monitoring
because it's per service that you've
defined inside of kubernetes because you
have a series of micro services that
you've deployed and you said these
services are going to talk to each other
and so forth you can get all of this
additional information now it might be a
little bit hard to see here but the key
thing to take away is we have automatic
SLO and era budget calculations so if
you think into yourself you know ok I
buy the whole era budget thing I buy the
whole SLO SLI SLA kind of thing but how
do I actually go implement that's like
don't tell me that I have to do
something just do it for me stackdriver
literally has done that for you
handful of clicks inside of the UI and
it's actually telling you this graph
right here is actually your error budget
graph this graph down here is your
service level objective compliance
meaning if this this graph is going like
really low and it goes down below that
you
your SLO your era budgets going to be
crazy high and then you can correlate it
with specific events so like who broke
production figure out who that was
figure out what the thing was that they
were able to get away with because we
want to have a blameless postmortem type
culture and then figure out how to
automate that from ever happening again
this is this is a wonderful tool to be
able to help you out with that the other
thing I want to talk about which some
people use stackdriver service
monitoring by the way a lot of the
network stuff that it grabs is all
coming from sto which is really cool you
can get an actual service topology graph
but the next one I want to talk about is
trace now as we move to distributed
systems and we have more and more micro
services working the hard problem
becomes why is the site slow or why is
something else slow it's not just a case
of one specific service that we can go
if thought well there it is a specific
call to a front-end might invoke dozens
of micro services on the backends if all
but one of them is having a problem or
excuse me if all but one of them is
working properly you won't necessarily
know which one of the micro services is
going to be at fault you really want to
know ah it was that micro service that's
having a problem because let's say it's
overloaded or something like that you
need a distributed tracing framework we
released a white paper a few years ago
called dapper which was our solution to
solving sort of distributed tracing as a
result of that we ended up releasing the
white paper and the open source
community kind of picked it up if you've
heard of Zipkin that's sort of the open
source implementation of our dapper
methodology but there's a couple other
things that we can implement or work
with things like Jager if anyone's heard
of Jager or like open tracing things
like that but if you want this to just
work out of the box again that batteries
included sort of SRA and DevOps practice
this has already built in you've got
agent support for popular languages so I
think there's like over a half dozen
some up basically and unless you're like
writing COBOL or something like that
we've got a language that's going to
work it's going to be able to pick up
and integrate with
your codebase and also it works with
things like Zipkin collectors so if
you've already instrumented based off of
Zipkin we can pick that up and give you
a wonderful dashboard that shows you
exactly what's going on in your
infrastructure which great about that is
all of the different graphs that you
would want for all of the different
calls that you have regardless of the
number of micro services that it's going
to hit is is is served up in an easy to
digest way which makes debugging very
easy
speaking of debugging this is the last
thing I want to talk about in this area
which is stackdriver
debugging now just out of curiosity how
many people here by show of hands are
using spectrum ever trace Cars handful
of people is like three people how many
people are using stackdriver debug do
you work at Google so okay so there's
only like handful of people here now
that's really interesting it's really
surprising because this technology has
existed for quite a while and this is
how Google does this type of debugging
in real time when things go wrong number
one thing when an error happens is you
have to recover as quickly as possible
do the RC a afterwards but get that
recovery back online so that your users
are happy you don't want to be the
company that is you know losing a
million dollars an hour because
something isn't running properly
stackdriver debugging allows you to do
production debugging very simply again
agent support for popular languages and
SDK so you can integrate with all of
this stuff but essentially you can
insert breakpoints and things like that
and receive instrumentation from
something that you have deployed in
production it works great with say
kubernetes engine and it also works
great I believe with App Engine as well
which is really cool and here's the
really cool part at least for me it
integrates with your source control
management meaning it can even though
this line of code is admitting this
particular breakpoint
here's the debug information that you
want it that's really powerful because
you're always are going to run into a
situation where something in production
is going to die for some random reason
and you want to collect better
formation if that occurs and figure out
how to correct it development
environments often times don't 100%
match that of production obviously
DevOps best practice says that they
should as much as possible but it's
difficult to be able to get the little
fine-tune details that you might have
particularly if users are using the site
a little bit differently than something
else
so stackdriver debugging super-awesome
to be able to do that so if you take a
look at all of these things you can go
wow I can have automation I can start to
eliminate toil I can keep things simple
because we have specific tools built for
specific things and the SRA book tells
us that tools and culture are kind of
inextricably linked and we've got all of
these additional tools out of a box to
help with things like advanced SLO
calculation you can go from zero to like
production grade sort of sre best
practices with very little modification
to what you're doing you just pop it
take a look at some of the stuff that
we've got in our platform and take it
from there so last thing I want to talk
about which might be unique to our
platform as opposed to say other
platforms and whatnot is that we've got
help for if and when you need it this is
not a journey that I advise people take
by themselves we refer to customers as
partners because it's a joint
partnership that we embark on if you're
successful on our platform we're
successful if we just go hey here's all
of our products good luck and then
everything fails for you you're not
going to be happy and we're not going to
be happy as a result all of this stuff
has to happen in a nature of
collaboration back and forth if you've
got an interesting feature work with
your account team to try to get that
feature pushed up into production meet
with engineering leadership to get their
insight into what we see the future as
but we want insight from all of you as
well because we want to know what's
interesting in your industry so we can
incorporate that feedback a couple
things specifically with respect to sre
and sort of DevOps you type things we've
got customer reliability engineers and
we also have professional services is my
friend Eric here in the audience
it's not that Eric but thank you so my
mother friend was actually a PSO is a
member of a professional services
organization and they're working on a
like a specific offering to help you out
that's s o w driven or statement of work
driven to help evaluate some of the
stuff that you're working on and help
you actually transition applications up
to production but it's a little bit more
hands-on a little bit more detailed the
really cool thing is our customer
reliability engineers these are like
Google s Ari's that help work in your
company to take applications that you
have do that s re assessment and then
pull that into sort of a modern way of
thinking about things it's kind of
interesting part of the reason it's
interesting is because it's free but
part of the reason why it's also
interesting is because it requires a
substantial investment of your time to
be able to modernize that type of
application and actually get things
working really well I I highly recommend
either one of these types of services
depending on what your mix is depending
on what your fit is because we want to
see people start adopting this type of
better site reliability engineering
practices to leverage our platforms
understanding regionality and zone
allottee and figuring out how to make
sure you get that v 9 that you're
looking for by deploying really large
scale infrastructure x' that have proper
disaster recovery that adhere to all of
the principles that I was talking about
today so they're there now I kind of
went through this very quickly but I
wanted to save some time for some
questions and whatnot we've got some CRE
people that are here in case you've got
questions about CRE engagements or some
best practices and some other things and
I think I've got like what 10 minutes 15
minutes unlike that a good 15 to 50
minutes awesome so with that just to
recap so everyone's on the same page
this is what the anthos platform kind of
looks like these are all of the
components inside of it the big thing is
that you've got things like kubernetes
and sto you've got things like k native
you've got something that automatically
bids the containers for you you've got
something that monitor
it's and it runs on our platform in a
very easy and integrated way in other
words if you wanted to like put up some
blue hexagons and then match them with
the specific things I would say you've
got debugger for embracing risk you've
got speck driver service monitoring for
your solos
you've got composer to help you out with
something like eliminating toil or
additional automation deployment manager
or any other infrastructure as code type
offering stock driver trace super
important to try to figure out as you
move towards these micro services you've
got cloud build and spinnaker for your
release engineering and then lastly
you've got simplicity so with this it
integrated kind of bundled products that
we have that we call anthos that can run
kind of anywhere that has all of these
things sort of integrated it's very
simple to go from zero to whatever it is
that you want to be able to deploy in
production very quickly and with that
thanks a bunch
I'll be here to answer a bunch of
questions and chat with you after the
fact
[Music]